salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans questions aux sénateurs
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire de public
sénat et d'acropolis on reçoit un
sénateur une sénatrice pour répondra à
toutes vos questions cette semaine on a
le plaisir d'accueillir max brisson
bonjour bonjour ça va bien dans cette
année ça va très bien tout va bien super
vous êtes sénateur les républicains des
pyrénées atlantiques et essai vous
surtout qu'ils allaient poser vos
questions à ma guise pression puisque
c'est vrai c'est une rencontre bonjour à
vous si vous nous regardez actuellement
en direct sur twitter bonjour à vous si
vous nous regardez en replay sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt et bonjour
aussi à vous si vous nous écoutez en
podcast c'est bien vous qui allez poser
vos questions toutes les questions que
je vais vous poser ont été travaillés au
préalable avec les internautes
et avec sa ds et avec celles et ceux qui
donc là en direct vont échanger avec
nous on va passer une heure ensemble
avec plaisir avec plaisir j'espère bien
on va apprendre à vous connaître
on va apprendre à on va apprendre à
connaître votre parcours et on va
discuter avec vous des grands sujets
d'actualité politique et des sujets sur
lesquels vous travaillez en tant que
sénateur avant de parler de vous je
voudrais qu'on commence par un sujet
d'actualité chaude si je puis dire
c'était il ya c'était il ya trois jours
seulement le second tour des élections
municipales élections très particulière
cette année à cause du coc vide
élections municipales avec une véritable
vague verte en france on a vu et ville
de bordeaux lyon strasbourg passer
passer à la couleur verte
on commençait à parler avec vous là
juste avant le début de l'émission du
taux d'abstention pour vous le taux
d'abstention s'est pas seulement dû aux
qu'ovide plus globalement que ça alors
c'est beaucoup plus grave c'est un vrai
problème de relations entre nos
concitoyennes et la chose publique
parce que c'est un signal d'un profond
rejet de la démocratie représentative
les gens peuvent s'intéresser au contenu
de la chose publique
l'écologie quand on va cet art parler et
ça va veut pas dire pour autant qu'ils
se retrouvent aujourd'hui dans les
formes de démocratie représentative mais
c'est extrêmement inquiétant parce que
moi je suis un adepte de churchill et je
pense que c'est le pire des régimes à
l'exception de tous les autres et que
dans ce qu'on voit poindre pour
éventuellement remplacer la démocratie
représentative
quand on est un peu comme moi un sens de
l'histoire parce que c'est ma formation
d'origine
en europe est extrêmement inquiet et
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on aurait
investi le champ de la démocratie
représentative pour pour dire qu'il n'ya
rien de mieux que le suffrage universel
que de se présenter aux élections que
d'aller convaincre nous considérons on
peut le voir et d'autres formes de
partie civile et d'autres formes de
citoyenneté cotisations non ce qu'on
essaie de montrer actuellement mon le
fait parfois peur hélas pas et je vais
prendre par exemple d'exemple
d'actualité qui est cette convention et
croissance moyenne pour le climat mais
autoproclamé il au sort sur quelle base
de légitimité qu'elle est la
représentativité de ces ce groupe
d'hommes et de femmes celles à divers
pour fear on va parler de la vie région
et nancy voulait éviter ces gars là on
va parler de l'environnement ce qu'elle
est au combat et puis vous savez que mes
consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires
vont se succéder pour vous interroger et
puis deux parlementaires qui vont venir
sur ce plateau
jean-charles collard wac et député la
république en marge de l'isère et bruno
sido sénateur et l'ère de la haute marne
qui veulent vous parler du nucléaire des
pesticides notamment des dossiers que
vous connaissez bien et puis en dernière
partie c'est yves thréard éditorialiste
au figaro qu'il avoue parlera plutôt de
2022 on aura quitté le gouvernement
depuis bien longtemps
mais vous avez raison on va faire entrer
tam tran huy de public sénat
[Musique]
bon certes âme
mouassa france alors on parlera du
gouvernement tout à l'heure quand il
sera dévoilé pour l'instant il ya
d'autres choses à évoquer et notamment
ce qu'a dit ségolène royal ces derniers
jours sur ce que devrait être une
politique gouvernement et oui bonsoir
ségolène royal soit vous avez appelé à
une politique plus écologique plus
sociale plus démocratique qu'est ce que
cela veut dire concrètement alors
d'abord cela veut dire et c'est conforme
au fond go bon fonctionnement des
institutions et de la démocratie et la
démocratie française en particulier
d'abord cela veut dire que il faut
toujours tenir compte de ce qu'on dit
les électeurs dans les urnes
même si on nous le savons et la cia un
fort taux d'abstention dieu la crise
sanitaire mais dû peut-être aussi un
désaveu à l'égard de la politique en
général
donc ça c'est aussi un événement grave
sur lequel il faut absolument réfléchir
pour renouer le lien entre les citoyens
et la politique et notamment dans les
moments très importants du son les
moment du vote art concret comment
est-ce qu'on aurait concrètement
concrètement qu'est ce qu'est ce qui a
été dit dans les urnes avec cette forte
poussée notamment dans l'est dans les
mairies avec l'union de la gauche et des
écologistes
eh bien il s'est dit quand même quelque
chose de très important
donc il faut répondre à cette aspiration
plus à tout ce qui s'est dit et fait et
toutes les souffrances que l'on a vu
pendant trois ans avec la multiplication
des mouvements sociaux et ce qui
pourrait recourir l'égide en mon livre
sur la résilience française c'est que la
france a besoin d'apaisement je le
disais déjà avant le confinement vous
rendez compte rue parce que je livre est
sorti avant avant c'est à dire je disais
déjà que pour réussir la résilience
française c'est à dire la création d'un
nouvel équilibre après tous ces chocs
vécu pendant trois ans il fallait
changer de méthode gouverneur lors il ya
peut-être eu un changement une
convention en réponse à la crise
démocratique notamment emmanuel macron a
mis en place la convention citoyenne
pour le climat bien rendu ses
conclusions
on va essayer parlé un petit peu
précisément un de leurs propositions par
exemple emmanuel macron a retoqué
l'idée du
taxe sur les dividendes pour financer la
transition écologique vous qu'est ce que
vous auriez fait est ce que vous auriez
garder une telle proposition
je l'aurais mis en tout cas à l'étude
pourquoi parce qu'il est très important
que la richesse financière soit ne soit
pas moins taxé que le travail que les
revenus du capital donc les dividendes
ce sont les revenus du capital
ils doivent être taxés comme les revenus
du travail pourrait même imaginer qu'il
ne soit plus là ils le sont moins donc
il faudrait au moins égaliser les
taxations sur les revenus financiers et
sur les revenus du capital
et en plus c'est une bonne idée de
flécher pour dire éviter que l'on dit ça
fait d impôt supplémentaire d'ir et en
plus c'est un impôt citoyen puisqu'on va
le flécher sur la transition énergétique
vous auriez mis à l'étude ah oui je veux
j'aurais mis en débat à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat oui bien sûr une
autre proposition pour laquelle elle
apporte a été refermé directement la
limitation à 100 km/heure sur les
autoroutes est ce que vous comprenez la
position du président de la république
ça pouvait aussi rappeler bien sûr le
débats clivants sur les 80 kilomètres
heure oui je la comprends parce que moi
je ne suis qu on promet qu'il les
repousse et oui pourquoi
non pas que ce soit forcément une
mauvaise idée mais l'idée toute simple
c'est de dire quand on roule moins vite
on pollue moins
moi je ne suis pas pour une écologie
punitive ouailles et pour une écologie
qui verrouille les gens dans des
interdits il suffit de leur dire si vous
pouvez éviter de rouler plus vite rouler
moins vite vous produirez - donc pour
pour qu une écologie soit efficace il
faut s'appuyer sur la citoyenneté c'est
pas en faisant une accumulation
d'interdits là où il faut de l'écologie
punitive c'est contre la délinquance
environnementale les pollutions les gens
qui qui déboisent de façon illégale tout
ce que l'église il ya par exemple les
glucides qui n'allait pas même si vous
même si ça existe déjà
ce qui est important c'est pas forcément
de mettre des mots dans la constitution
c'est de mettre des actes d'un code
pénal pour sanctionner très sévèrement
face à l'écossé dans le quotidien
légalement polluent l'eau indirectement
ce serait ça c'est plus efficace lille
vraiment des sanctions très très forte
sur la destruction de l'environnement
mais sûre pour revenir à la vitesse sur
les autoroutes
le vrai à la vraie question c'est la
voiture propre c'est la voiture propre
donc moi je suis davantage sur une
une décision qui aura été la gratuité
des autoroutes pour les voitures
électriques par exemple là vous donner
un signal positif moi je suis pour
l'écologie positive
chaque fois que l'on veut encourager des
comportements différents et puis bien
évidemment et j'espère que ce sera dans
le plan de relance
un investissement très fort sur la
voiture électrique la voiture à
hydrogène les véhicules propres et donc
le nez fait par moments ce modèle de
borne de recharge rapide parce que c'est
ça qui freine le déploiement de la
voiture et ils ont les autoroutes sur
toutes les aires d'autoroute il devrait
y avoir plusieurs bornes de recharge les
voies de la rapide charge et là ce soir
vous mettez sur la télé hd qui la
gratuité des autoroutes pour les
voitures électriques
oui c'est pour montrer si vous voulez
que ce qu'on fait des interdits des
contraintes des libertés réduite soit on
fait du positif
et pour faire le positif il faut à la
fois faire de l'information disant
chaque fois que vous allez rouler moi
vous pollue rémois donc l'automobiliste
qui peut très bien choisir de rouler un
peu moins vite mais on va pas à baisser
comme ça autoritairement ya déjà eu dans
le confinement suffisamment de de
liberté contraintes que à la sortie du
confinement entendre qu'on va encore
interdire et diminuer la vitesse sur les
autoroutes
ce sont deux lieux de sécurisation non
je pense que c'est peut-être sur les
avions maintenant oui aujourd'hui le
transport aérien et bien il est pointé
du doigt et il est notamment question de
supprimer les lignes aériennes pour les
courts trajets qui peuvent être
remplacés par des trajets en train de
2h30 et dans le même temps on voit qu'il
ya bien des emplois à la clé par exemple
bien on voit les suppressions chez hop
on parle de plus de 1000 suppressions
d'emplois lors qu'est ce que vous
privilégiez vous dans ce cas de figure
l'économie ou l'écologie et la
suppression de ces de ses avions l'idéal
c'est de ne pas avoir à choisir entre
les deux voyez c'est de faire en sorte
que la croissance verte soit créatrice
d'activité et d'emploi et la conquête
alors la construction en est le
gouvernement veut les sucrés mais
concrètement le principe est bon dire
chaque fois qu'il ya un train encore
faut-il qu'il y en ait suffisamment
parce que souvent il ya je vais vous
interrompt la moria je suis désolé on y
reviendra
alexis kohler s'apprête à lancer
gouvernement bonsoir
sur proposition du premier ministre le
président de la république a nommé
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
madame barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports monsieur bruno le maire
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance madame florence parly
ministre des armées
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur madame elisabeth bornes
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion
monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre-mer
madame jacqueline gourault ministre de
la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice madame
roselyne bachelot ministre de la culture
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame annick
girardin ministre de la mer
madame frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
madame amélie
de montchalin ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique sont nommé ministre délégué
auprès du premier ministre monsieur marc
fesneau chargé des relations avec le
parlement et de la participation
citoyenne
madame elisabeth moreno chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances auprès du ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères monsieur
franck riester chargé du commerce
extérieur et de l'attractivité auprès de
la ministre de la transition écologique
madame emmanuelle wargon chargé du
logement
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari chargé
des transports auprès du ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
monsieur olivier du soft chargé des
comptes publics
madame agnès pannier run h est chargé de
l'industrie monsieur alain griset chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
madame roxana maracineanu chargé des
sports auprès de la ministre des armées
madame geneviève darrieussecq chargée de
la mémoire et des anciens combattants
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
madame marlène schiappa chargé de la
citoyenneté auprès de la ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame brigitte klinkert chargé de
l'insertion auprès de la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
madame nadia est chargé de la ville
auprès du ministre des solidarités et de
la santé madame brigitte bourguignon
chargé de l'autonomie est nommé
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre monsieur gabriel attal
porte-parole du gouvernement le
président de la république réunira le
conseil des ministres avec l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement ce mardi 7
juillet à 15 heures je vous remercie
voilà donc pour le nouveau gouvernement
castex une première réaction ségolène
royal quand vous voyez c'est que oui je
n'étais pas invitée pour commenter le
gouvernement veut relancer l'activité
non je pense qu'il ya des choses
intéressantes sur des concepts nouveaux
comme l'insertion la citoyenneté dont il
ya une prise de conscience peut-être de
des fractures territoriales des
fractures sociales qui se sont exprimées
depuis trois ans voilà maintenant vous
voyez une inflexion là quelque chose qui
change je veux dire il ya dix ans on va
voir comment on va voir ce qu'elle sera
exactement le contenu mais c'est vrai
que vous reconnaître aussi que ces
éléments-là son nouveau je regarde ce
qu'est jésus devant cet accord doit
ensuite bon il ya l'équipe sortante
quasiment reconduit temps des quelques
modifications près et puis c'est un
gouvernement qui reste très la
république en marche
donc s'il n'ya pas de changement
tournant sur l'écologie sur l'écologie
il n'y a pas ces barbares a compris que
j'avais connu particulière sur
l'écologie on va pas la force écologique
dans ce groupe et donner le rôle d'une
secrétaire d'état marc baïetto d'affilée
une femme très la biodiversité les
travailleuses à être sérieuse elle est
travailleuse et elle connaît bien son
sujet et une femme de conviction dans
quelle phase seront sans doute bien son
travail vous avez pour tenir le choc
dans ce ministère où il ya eu beaucoup
de démission parce que quand vous
regardez la brièveté de la durabilité
des ministres de l'environnement dans
leurs postes
elle est très courte et donc il faut
tenir pour tenir le choc je veux tenir
le choc face aux autres ministères et en
particulier au ministère de l'économie
et des finances alors quels conseils
donneriez quels conseils vous lui de la
vrille et culture c'est ça que je
conseille vous lui donneriez quels
conseils donnerais 2
voilà de ne pas lâcher de ne pas lâcher
sur les convictions et sur les
perspectives à atteindre et sur les
objectifs à obtenir ces des combats vous
les jugez pas au sein d'un gouvernement
vous l'a jugé apte à encaisser ce choc
vous le dites se fasse à je transmets
une vie sans expérience d'abord parce
qu'elle est parlementaire
elle a déjà été donc elle connaît bien
le mystère de de l'environnement est la
dérive parce qu'elle a été elle
travaillait comme secrétaire d'état la
biodiversité elle a fait du très bon
travail
donc elle a tout pour réussir mais il
faut une force politique c'est à dire
que c'est à dire que pour réussir des
arbitrages si elle veut remettre le
crédit d'impôt de transition énergétique
ou si elle veut revenir parce que
l'enjeu c'est de revenir sur la
trentaine de recul qui était qui a été
acquis et le passif du gouvernement
précédent et en la matière en matière
d'amour dire environnementales entre les
permis d'hydrocarbures la suppression du
crédit d'impôt
la suppression des territoires énergie
positive la baisse des tarifs de rachat
des énergies éoliennes en mer
la suppression des subventions à
l'agriculture bio les les suppressions
aussi de l'affaiblissement dans les
normes de protection des espaces
naturels classés puis un transfert de
responsabilités au niveau local donc
avec tous les risques que cela compense
son local de pression locale
l'affaiblissement des normes sur les
établissements classés notamment ce qui
explique qu'elle a une sacrée liste de
courses là oui il suffit de reprendre la
trentaine de recul et déjà de remettre à
niveau par rapport à ces reculs l'a
ensuite il ya l'application de l'img
l'accord de paris sur le climat dont qui
est un peu à l'arrêt par exemple
l'alliance solaire internationale est la
règle donc il ya beaucoup de quoi est dû
ce qu'on appelle les coalitions actions
qui sont à l'arrêt quelle il faut
redonner une impulsion et puis surtout
accéléré cette transition c'est l'air
veiller à ce que dans le plan de relance
la dimension environnementale soit
massive et que les subventions ne soit
pas soit bien conditionnés en les
banques continuent à financer les
énergies fossiles et les aides données à
la
à l'automobile et à l'aviation dont ils
l'ont été sans contrepartie dans le dans
le prolongement du gouvernement
précédent également celui quelques
arrivées surprenant par exemple l'avocat
eric dupond moretti qui devient garde
des sceaux le retour de roselyne
bachelot et qui cette fois ci prend le
portefeuille de la culture qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire à l'envi géante vous
essayez quand un nouveau gouvernement
arrive on lui souhaite de réussir
oui pour vous souhaiter parce que voyez
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
et la crise sanitaire que la crise
économique massive qui se profile à la
rentrée et notamment sur les jeunes je
pense qu'une priorité sur la question
des jeunes il ya sept cent mille jeunes
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail
il ya une les jeunes sont en grande
situation de précarité après le
confinement et n'ont pas pu accéder aux
jobs d'été ils ont perdu leurs places en
apprentissage donc un des problèmes les
plus dramatiques à régler aujourd'hui
par anticipation sans attente septembre
c'est la question d'instituer l'on
veuille revenir justement on va on va
remercier tam parce que c'est brigitte
boucher qui varient tout à leur mercie
table mais encore encore un petit mot
parce que vous disiez c'est un
gouvernement très la république en
marche
ça veut dire quoi dans votre esprit non
on disait par exemple qu'il y aurait
quelque chose de spectaculaire sur le
fond d'écologie
oui il ya une ministre écologiste par
exemple ils se perdent et hyman wargon
elle pas écologiste elle viendra des
colos des écologistes vous dire marins
pompiers vient devient de l'écologie
mais par exemple corps très la
république en marche oui ça veut dire
que ça se replie un peu sur soi oui on
va pas on voit pas l'évolution politique
par rapport à l'équipe précédente
même si l entrée de la société un peu de
là un peu de rentrées de la société
civile et puis des concepts nouveaux
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
oui maintenant vous regardez aux ânes il
faut souhaiter bonne route bon vent et
bonne réussite
maintenant on va cueillir brigitte
boucher de lcp assemblée nationale
soir brigitte danseurs francis jeanson
est mort hier
alors après avoir été très critique sur
la crise sanitaire le déconfinement
aujourd'hui vous diriez qu'il est bien
gérée ou pas de toute façon ça fait
plaisir le déconfinement donc vous voyez
c'est pas là c'est pas la même comment
dirais-je stratégie d' analyse en train
un confinement et un déconfinement ce
qu'il y a peut-être quand on entend les
filières professionnelles se prononcer
notamment sur la question du tourisme
sur la question des hôtels sur la
question des restaurants il ya des
restrictions qui sont parfois
incohérentes puisque voyait des
terrasses de cafés bondées et à côté des
restaurants ou des hôtels qui n'ont pas
le droit d'ouvrir
donc ça c'est voilà il ya une souffrance
je pense dans tout tout ce secteur des
pme de l'hôtellerie de la restauration
et ça je pense qu'il faut le dcau le
régler assez vite
la seconde chose ce sont les festivals
de l'été c'est la culture paye un très
très lourd tribut
la crise sanitaire et ça risque d'être
très douloureux parce que j'aime
beaucoup de chômage ce sont souvent des
entreprises qui sont déjà assez fragile
et la suppression de tous les festivals
s'impose comme un problème
est ce qu'il y avait pas une solution s
qui a pas encore une solution pour
sauver un certain nombre de festivals
rues de la chaux qui devra y répondre de
là avec des gestes bien sûr avec des
circonstances sanitaires et puis l'école
la reprise de l'école qui a fait
tellement plaisir aux enfants que tu
réussisses aux enseignants où ils
étaient très courts et certains auraient
souhaité que l'école puisse continuer
jusqu'au 15 juillet par exemple mais ça
n'a pas été fait et ça a repris il
fallait que ça absolument que ça
reprenne
même si ça a été beaucoup trop confiné
l'école puisque tous les médecins disent
qu'elle ait pas beaucoup de risques dans
l'école et pourtant ça a été quand même
dramatiquement confiné sauf qu'on voit
qu'il ya des foyers qui reviennent des
clusters qu'on craint éventuellement une
deuxième vague et qu'est ce que vous
feriez vous si vous étiez à la place du
gouvernement en cas de deuxième vague
est ce qu'il faudrait par exemple
confiné ou pas mais bon avant d'attendre
la deuxième vin il faut être prêt et la
france est prête à vos yeux
elle l'est pas encore je crois que le
miz de la santé y travaille mais
puisqu'on a l'expérience de la première
vague
il faut écouter les personnels soignants
et en particulier faut répondre à leurs
préoccupations parce que là ils sont
encore dans la rue mais par exemple
pas assez de test n'est pas bon les deux
l'humain de vue les personnels soignants
les personnels soignants dans l'hôpital
aujourd'hui alors que les négociations
ont commencé le 25 mai n'ont toujours
pas satisfaction donc ça c'est l'urgence
de la semaine qui vient parce que
imaginer une seconde vague alors que les
personnels soignants déjà fatigués sont
encore plus fatigué parce qu'ils doivent
revendiquer les décisions qu'on leur
apporte même porté sur eux vous pensez
si on pourra compter sur eux mais vaut
mieux compter sur eux s'ils ont des
personnels soignants bien rémunérés
rémunéré rasséréné content de la
priorité pour vous augmentez les
personnels soignants et oui c'est
puisque ça a été promis oui avec la
france et au 27e jour bas c'est toujours
par s'est toujours pas fait gouverner
c'est apporter des solutions
et ça c'est une urgence ne serait ce que
pour la souffrance de ces personnels
soignants par leur respect qu'on leur
doit ne peut pas les avoir applaudi tous
les soirs et aujourd'hui ne pas passer
aux actes quant au respect qu'on leur
doit le ségur de la santé feu devrait
être bientôt voilà alors ce serait
annoncée même dans les prochains jours
il ya quand même des solutions qui sont
sur la table on parle de 15 milliards
d'euros pour la rénovation des bâtiments
du matériel et 7 milliards pour les
salaires est ce que vous cette enveloppe
là elle vous paraître suffisante ou pas
je crois que à force de parler d'
enveloppe financière on ne sait pas ce
que ça veut dire les enveloppes
voyez donc il faut savoir ce qui ce que
ça permet de faire parce que c'est pas
en lançant comme ça des enveloppes les
français n'y croient plus aux enveloppes
comme ça qu'on lance et puis souvent je
vais vous dire d'expérience le ministère
des finances lance des enveloppes et
puis après ils cherchent surtout comment
ne pas dire de dépenser l'enveloppent
c'est systématique là il ya plus de 20
milliards qui sont mis sur la table on
sait qu'en même temps ils annoncent les
jambes
les gens ne croient plus aux annonces il
croit à ce qu'ils voient ce qu'ils
peuvent toucher ce qu'ils peuvent
éventuellement contrôle et donc ce qui
est important c'est de savoir quels sont
les critères retenus
et on sait que la bonne solution pour
les personnels soignants c'est d'aligner
les rémunérations des personnels
soignants sur les rails la rémunération
des fonctionnaires de l'état ou des
fonctionnaires des collectifs dont du
président
qui sont ceux à qui il faudrait plus
d'argent pour les salaires puisque nous
sommes au 25e rang des salaires qui a un
nombre de postes vacants considérable
parce que les salaires ne sont
suffisamment pas élevé par rapport à la
dureté des tâches et du métier il faut
impérativement d'ailleurs ça a été
promis par le président de la république
revaloriser ces salaires et tout cela
avec un plan de relance économique qui
se profile alors un plan global qui est
attendu à la rentrée
pour vous quelles sont les priorités sur
quoi faudrait-il accès ce grand plan de
relance alors je les dis déjà avec des
propositions très précises que nous
avons fait après avoir nié avoir
travaillé notamment sur la transition
énergétique
donc on le sait maintenant ça a été
répété mille fois mais il faut lancer il
faut que l'état accepte de lancer des
chantiers publics en lançant des appels
à projets et des travaux qui peuvent
démarrer vite comme on faisait dans les
territoires énergie positive qui sont
qui ont été supprimés on pourrait les
rétablir ces territoires à énergie
positive à revoir à pau pelli qui les a
bien connu 20 pts avoir cette idée
pourquoi parce que c'est du super u en
tout cas parce que c'est très rapide on
délègue les moyens financiers aux
collectivités locales est pour la liste
des bâtiments rénovés
elles peuvent lancer les appels à
projets les marchés publics et les
travaux peuvent comme tout maintenant
les conseils municipaux sont tous en
place
surtout les consistoires d'ailleurs donc
c'est une force de frappe les conseils
municipaux de clavary aux idées de ce
plan de relance et la transition
écologique
oui c'est la transition que pourquoi
parce que c'est le bâtiment vous
connaissez quand le bâtiment va tout va
on serre est ce vrai et c'est ces deux
sont des emplois non délocalisables et
en plus des opportunités de mettre des
jeunes en formation professionnelle en
apprentissage sur ce nouveau métier de
la rénovation des bâtiments d énergie
renouvelable de la biodiversité du
nettoyage des forêts donc il ya beaucoup
de la reine de la rénovation des légers
je fais cette proposition la rénovation
des circuits d'eau souterrains et les
compères entre 30 et 70 % gaspillage
d'eau parce que les réseaux souterrains
de distribution d'eau ne sont plus en
état
voilà ça c'est des chantiers qui sont
très importants alors parce que tout ça
c'est pour lutter contre le chômage
alors oui le président la république a
donné une interview il a dit qu'il
fallait rompre avec cette maladie
française qui est la préférence pour le
chômage
est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
ça je pense que l'expression alors je
sais pas dans quel à quelle occasion
cette expression est pourquoi est ce
qu'elle allait endurer la presqu île
lu et relu à mai mais c'est dur pour les
gens d'entendre ça parce que tous ceux
qui ont perdu leur travail
toutes les entreprises qui sont en
faillite toutes les pme qui sont épuisés
dans les gens font pas le choix du
président devrait pas parler comme ça je
vais pas aller jusque là parce que je
pense qu'il a eu il a eu de bonnes
raisons de dire cela mais je sais par le
ressenti des gens voyez c'est pas ça je
parle dans mon livre justement de des
chocs reçus par le dénigrement lorsque
les gens qui ont perdu leur travail ou
qui ont peur de ne pas retrouver ou qui
sont en faillite qui peuvent plus payer
leur loyer etc qui entendent 5 ils font
le choix du chômage et puis les pays
étrangers qui dit qui entend à présent
la république dire mon pays fait le
choix du chômage déjà qu'on est
caricaturé par certains pays en dix ans
les français ils ont le sens où le temps
vacances etc préfère les vacances au
travail si nous mêmes on parce que même
si le président de la république c'est
le président la règle et projette sur
nous ce type de vision c'est pas très
bon pour la force économique du pays il
dernière question alors une réforme qui
est en cours qui a été stoppée c'est la
réforme des retraites le président a dit
qu'elle qu'elle devrait reprendre pour
vous c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
et pourtant on attend un déficit qui
devrait être proche des 30 milliards
d'ici la fin 2020 alors est-ce qu'il
faut la faire ou pas la faire c'est pas
au contraire le moment de la faire
écouter honnêtement je pense y ait un
consensus parmi des non seulement les
partenaires sociaux mais aussi mais
aussi les français qui entendent ça
beaucoup de maires d'ailleurs qui ceux
qui ont été très étonnés d'entendre que
on va encore perdre du temps sur la
réforme des retraites
il ya déjà tellement de choses à faire
par rapport à la grave très grave mais
mia consensus sauf au gouvernement parce
que ce gouvernement lui veut y aller
jean castex a dit moi j'ai pas envie de
consensus mou y qui envoyait d'un court
terme et l'année oui parce qu'un
gouvernement n'aime pas remettre en
cause des choses qu'il a dites avant
sauf que lorsqu'un nouveau produit sur
le recul je fais autre chose c'est pour
montrer s'il ya une continuité etc
c'est une erreur cette ancienne idée qui
consiste à dire dès que vous renoncez à
une réforme
on va dire que vous ne voulez plus rien
réformer c'est une erreur de faire ça
mais je pense surtout que c'est
impossible c'est impossible c'est du
temps perdu leurs enfants c'est
impossible il ya une justice dans cette
réforme par points
mais c'est impossible dans le contexte
là aujourd'hui la priorité c'est le
chômage c'est la précarité c'est la
grande pauvreté c'est les retards
scolaires pris part de nombreux enfants
c'est la souffrance des personnes de
grand âge
songez qu'il ya eu six cent cinquante
mille personnes qui sont restées seules
deux grands âges qui sont resté seul
pendant tout le confinement dont
beaucoup se sont laissées mourir avec
des familles qui n'ont pas pu les
accompagner donc il ya aussi des
séquelles de souffrance psychologique
qu'il faut impérativement prendre en
considération merci brigitte êtres d'une
audition publique comme tous les lundis
et c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir un
système au cours de cette saison qui se
sait dernier numéro de la saison mais on
va y revenir et on va accueillir
maintenant les parlementaires qui vont
débattre avec vous ségolène royal on va
d'abord fait
[Musique]
les parlementaires vont arriver je
voulais vous demander aussi il est
beaucoup question du rsa jeunes
oui pour les moins de 25 ans ça n'existe
pas ça divise la majorité vous parliez
des jeunes tout à l'heure qui vont
arriver sur le marché de l'emploi 700
milles ça va être difficile
seriez vous favorable à rsa jeunes
seriez vous favorable à un rsa jeunes
est ce que je voyais oui oui et
quelqu'un qui nettoie les et
parlementaires arrive tout se passe bien
la taxe mais favorable à rsa jeunes je
pense que c'est une bonne idée
pourquoi c'est une bonne idée parce
qu'il est une grande précarité chez les
jeunes mais c'est pareil il faut pas que
ça donne un signal de les jeunes n'ont
plus accès l'april a ma préférence va à
l'emploi pour les jeunes
ensuite à la formation professionnelle
donc si on fait un récit un jeune ça
permet de gérer le problème de la
précarité des jeunes et ça c'est un
grave problème la précarité des jeunes
avec évolua version avec avec un volet
insertion obligatoire formation
professionnelle stages en entreprise
était un il faut apprendre amitié vous
êtes favorable au rsa jouer je pense que
c'est dans le contexte de grande
précarité des jeunes
ce serait une façon de leur redonner une
espérance pour le futur alors ségolène
royal
les parlementaires sont arrivés sur ce
plateau vous vous demandiez ce qui se
passait alors je vous explique
j'explique à tout le monde
on nettoie les bureaux entre chaque
intervention parce que nous étions bien
à l'antenne bonsoir jean charles
kohlhaas roi vous et député la
république en marge de l'isère et
bonsoir bruno sido vous êtes sénateur
les républicains de la haute-marne et
vous allez pouvoir pendant une dizaine
de minutes
échanger avec ségolène royal on va
commencer peut être par vous bruno sido
vous voulez parler du nucléaire parce
que dans votre circonscription il ya bur
notamment mais l'actualité c'est aussi
fessenheim oui madame royal moi je
voudrais vous parler de l'actualité
c'est la fermeture de fessenheim
parce que moi je considère que et
beaucoup avec moi considère que à la
fois c'est un un gâchis est un non-sens
dachy gâchis humain de jeu pour
commencer parce que beaucoup de
personnes très compétentes qui est bon
et financier parce que cette centrale
c'était le président de l'asn qui le
disait était la plus une des plus sûres
de france parce qu'elle venait de subir
sa révision décennale
et puis non sens parce qu'au fond cette
électricité qui ne s'est pas produit tdf
rien de le dire on va être obligé
probablement cet hiver sauf si les
douces ou s'il n'y a pas de problème
d'importer de l'électricité pour qui
n'est pas de coupure et cette
électricité viendront d'allemagne et de
la pollution du lignite et donc beaucoup
de co2 quant à la suisse puisque
finalement la suisse est également
propriétaire de en partie à 15% de slime
elle apportera de nuit de l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire pour faire
fonctionner ces step station transférer
pompage vous serez bon et ce qui lui
permettra de dire que la de l'électro
c'était complètement décarbonés donc au
fond l'écologie parce que ce qui est
important de monde c'est le
réchauffement climatique c'est le co2
par conséquent il ya un vrai problème
qu'il faudrait tranché je voudrais
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que vous en
pensez
bon en plus c'est moi qui ai signé vous
avez le décrète une voiture est retoquée
par en avril 2010 est oui bac et de
voisins qui était ensuite confirmé oui
enfin vous lors duquel est en train
d'être fermés et dont il est fermé mais
là cette centrale d'abord c'est une des
plus anciennes centrales qui n'est plus
aux normes ce et s il fallait
aujourd'hui quoi construire fessenheim
tels que et fessenheim
on vous le savez on aurait plus
l'autorisation de construire fessenheim
puisqu'une nouvelle centrale sont
beaucoup plus sécurisée notamment avec
le double confinement et c'est ensuite
cette centrale en zone sismique qui en
plus est en dessous du niveau
voilà donc si un problème systémique
c'est à dire et il peut y avoir une
pollution de l'eau de la rivière
et ça je pense que en plus c'est une
centrale qui était tout le temps en
panne quand vous regardez la
programmation des réacteurs du réacteur
de fusionnel vous voyez tout le temps
des pannes à fessenheim donc à quel prix
est ce que ça a été remise aux normes
provisoirement sans doute et donc la
vraie question c'est le coup comparative
des différentes énergies et quand on dit
que l'énergie nucléaire est moins cher
que les énergies renouvelables ce n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui notamment être
le coup de retraitement des déchets vous
le savez l'investissement le fameux
grand carénage vers l'investissement
nécessaire à la remise aux normes de
toutes les centrales puisque la plupart
vont arriver à l'échéance de vie
c'est-à-dire à l'échéance de 40 ans et
donc la vraie question c'est c
les énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui
l'énergie solaire produit une énergie ou
beaucoup moins cher et moi qu'est
l'énergie nucléaire doit pas vous
contredire pour le plaisir mais quand on
annonce 60 60 euros le mégawatt pour
l'éolien c'est juste faux c'est au
quasiment le double parce que quand il
ya pas de vent il faut bien avoir de
l'électricité quand même et maman ont
besoin de faire chauffer leurs biberons
etc etc et donc il faut quand même des
usines d'un côté et pour assurer la
continuité de la production
d'électricité est donc là il ya un
langage qui n'est pas admissible parce
qu'on ne dit pas la vérité aux français
l'idée ce n'est pas de supprimer le
nucléaire c'est eux disent était de
diminuer la part du nucléaire puisqu'on
avait 75 % de production d'électricité
après que l'anglais même 80 il dit c'est
l'objectif c'est de rabaisser à 50
moi j'avais mis à 2025 nouveau
gouvernement a reporté de dix ans encore
un chantier pour bordeaux et je trouve
ça dommage pourquoi parce que plus vous
reculez - les investisseurs dans les
énergies renouvelables sont motivés pour
investir parce qu'il se dit bon ben j'ai
encore dix ans pour le nucléaire et on
va pas nous donner les parlementaires
avaient de mon truc c'était pas possible
en 25 ans est louable comme aurait comme
objectif l'humilité il aurait été tant à
ce moment-là de repousser éventuellement
si vous décourager les industriels du
renouvelable en leur disant ben on en
prend encore pour dix ans du nucléaire
ils investissent plus et doit le
ralentissement des investissements et
notamment dans les nouvelles
technologies par exemple l'éolien en mer
l'éolien flottant
on va passer les loteries de rachat
l'éolien flottant était a été rabaissé
sa c2 alors jean charcot la roi qui est
ici lui veut vous parler revenir sur la
convention citoyenne sur le climat est
beaucoup fait parler ces derniers jours
moi même tout à fait sur le nucléaire je
note quand même que il s'agissait d'une
promesse de françois hollande et de la
mandature précédente de fermer
fessenheim d'ici 2017 et que c'est nous
mêmes qui l'avons mise en place puisque
c'est nous mêmes qui le kilo ferment moi
je me réjouis déjà de convergence de vue
je vous ai écoutés depuis le début de
l'émission sur une écologie positive
plus que punitive et puis sur le fait de
ré concilier écologie et économie voilà
ce sont des sujets sur lequel je pense
qu'on a une vision partagée et c'est
intéressant de le noter en un chantier
encore aujourd'hui c'est de mieux
associer les citoyens aux prises de
décisions et aux débats et la conférence
climatique avec ses 150 citoyens a
montré que c'était possible de trouver
du consensus pendant ces neuf mois de
travail et j'ai donc été très très
surpris que vous disiez que finalement
un référendum comme ils l'appellent de
leurs voeux sur par exemple la réforme
de la constitution
et bien qu'un référendum n'avait pas de
sens à vos yeux alors même que je vous
pensais très favorables à la démocratie
délibérative ou participative c'était un
des thèmes de votre campagne
présidentielle donc pourquoi tant de
réticences aujourd'hui par rapport à
cette convention est une possibilité de
référendum parce que je pense qu'il ya
urgence et qu'on sait ce qu'il faut
faire et si on perd du temps dans un
référendum qui va politiser un débat qui
va coûter cher qui va prendre du temps
et qui forcément schématique scar
affaire un homme c'est en oui ou non
alors qu'on sait ce qu'il faut faire et
que l'urgence et l'investissement pour
reprendre l'exemple de fessenheim ce que
j'avais proposée en fermant fessenheim
c'est le conte est installée la fameuse
usine franco-allemande de tesla puisqu
il ose même vu et l'odm est monté dans
sa voiture et lui dit mais c'est hélas à
fessenheim dans une zone franco allemand
n'a constitué que l'on pourrait mettre
l'usiné européenne sur fessenheim avec
des batteries électriques c'est les
revenus c'est à dire réussir cette
transition en redonnant de l'espoir
quand quelque chose ferme pour redonner
de l'espoir et j'espère qu'il y aura une
mutation et la seconde chose c'est de
faire de fessenheim et sergent ce que
vous dites c'est à dire on peut aussi
imaginer des voiliers des consultations
locales par rapport aux préoccupations
des mutations des bassins d'emploi c'est
de faire en sorte que fessenheim soit
vous savez il ya quatre cinq centrales à
travers le monde à démanteler 400 donc
les mêmes marché mondial colossal donc
en faire un chantier exemplaire du
démantèlement des centrales et capter le
marché mondial du démantèlement des
centrales ça c'est une piste mais je
reviens je lis les choses commençaient
leur voix pour montrer qu'on sait dans
tous les domaines ce qu'il faut faire
donc c'est le gouvernement qui doit
prendre ses responsabilités c'est ce que
voulait dire
gouvernement les entreprises je veux
dire c'est du local c'est tentant de
créer du consensus
faire un don mais vous vous poseriez
quelles questions par exemple sur la
réforme de la constitution
voyez mettre l'environnement dans
l'article la préservation de
l'environnement dans l'article 1er de la
constitution on les mois j'ai été
rapporteur de la loi hydrocarbures dite
loi hulot qui a permis d'éviter 50
signatures de permis depuis qu'elle est
en place 2010 cette année dit oui mais
parce que justement on se heurte dans la
constitution au respect des droits des
entreprises et à la liberté
d'entreprendre et met cette préservation
de l'environnement cette préservation de
la biodiversité à l'article 1er au même
titre que la liberté d'entreprendre et
bien c'est une avancée majeure pour
faire ch alors non mais je veux dire
c'est pas fini enfin je veux dire c'est
plutôt positif ou sonic c'est un non
sens que ça ne faisait aucun sens à ce
que vous savez pourquoi parce que le
risque c'est quoi c'est qu'on réforme la
constitution et qu'on fasse rien
d'autres noms en se donnant bonne leçon
j'étais dans la constitution il ya tout
il ya le droit à la santé aussi bien
regarder les personnels de santé sont
obligés encore de manifester donc ce que
je veux pas c'est que la politique se
résume à des principes on se fait
plaisir en mettant sur la constitution
il ya déjà la charte de l'environnement
dans la constitution nationale accords
de paris sur le climat qui doit être
appliqué dans tous les textes on les a
donc maintenant on a besoin d'action ça
ne fait pas de mal de médecins dans la
constitution je suis d'accord avec vous
mais le risque j'ai tellement vu
des responsables politiques se faire
plaisir avec des mots des lois sans se
préoccuper de leurs applications
alors qu'aujourd'hui face à la crise
économique et au risque d'une lente du
chômage
l'environnement devient une valeur et un
levier pour créer des activités des
emplois c'est ça moi qui m'intéressent
bruno sido vous voulez vous évoquez un
autre sujet que sont les pesticides
parce que ça c'est un sujet qui est
vraiment alors j'allais dire ça fait des
années et même des décennies qu'on en
parle et il ya toujours ce conflit-là
entre environnement et agriculture et
les pesticides les agriculteurs à vrai
dire je voudrais je part du constat que
la france qui était le premier premier
pays agricole au moment de la création
du marché commun etc etc est maintenant
dépassée par l'allemagne alors c'était
c'est assez étonnant et on se demande
pourquoi les français ont besoin de de
s'intéresser tout cela et ont besoin de
têtes de turc éventuellement alors c'est
le round up c'est le nucléaire bombe en
plein dans le sujet à vrai dire j'ai eu
affaire au sénat un excellent ministre
de l'agriculture par ailleurs monsieur
le foll qui nous disait à la fois il
faut faire de l'agriculture durable et
depuis la bourre et parce que le carbone
dans le sol et ses accès et en même
temps et en même temps c'était un loyer
qui existaient déjà et supprimer le
roundup
ça n'est pas possible et par conséquent
ce que demandent les agriculteurs c'est
que bien entendu ils sont dans
l'environnement permanence tous les
jours mais c'est qu'on leur donne le
temps de s'adapter et qu'on leur propose
des solutions alternatives
je cite le round up parce que c'est à la
mode
on pourrait citer des insecticides etc
et donc là les les les agriculteurs sont
très inquiet et attendre et qu'on aille
dans le bon sens que le gouvernement il
dans le bon sens et comprennent les
problèmes dorsaux les agriculteurs c'est
que voulait dire absolument
on peut souvent sauvé une agriculture
sans pesticides
non parce que les consommateurs veulent
maintenant manger sainement ils veulent
plus manger de pesticides est ce qu'on
sait que c'est cancérigène est
d'ailleurs le taux de cancers chez les
agriculteurs est supérieur au taux de
cancer de la moyenne à ça les
viticulteurs par exemple un viticulteur
les viticulteurs ont beaucoup beaucoup
de cancers et même l'âge de la puberté
vous savez dans les familles des petites
filles
qui sont allés famille de viticulteurs
ils ont la plupart quitté à l'âge de 8 9
ans et les perturbateurs endocriniens
aussi sont dramatiques sur le tout
l'appareil reproduire productif
du coup du corps humain donc ça je pense
qu'on peut même même pour protéger les
agriculteurs on peut pas passer ça sous
silence
il faut forcer les industries chimiques
à mettre sur le marché des produits
nocifs d'apporter des alternatives et de
temps qui aura pas de contraintes là
pour le couffo de la contrainte les les
industries chimiques elles ont intérêt à
vendre des produits qui sont déjà
amortis dans les brevets sont déjà
amortis donc l'intérêt des agriculteurs
comme l'intérêt de la nation et
l'intérêt des consommateurs
c'est d'exiger de l'industrie chimique
elle met sur le marché des produits
nocifs et ça existe mais ça leur coûte
plus cher donc elles vont pas me les
mettre sur le marché tant mieux je peux
oui mais ça leur coûte plus cher c'est
sûr que ça ait mais oui c'est
indispensable parce que l'agriculture
avec zéro produit pour protéger la
nature ça ne peut pas marcher ça
n'existe pas non il faut des produits
pour protéger et ça je suis d'accord
mais ma taille et des produits non
aussitôt fait un bon boulot il c'est
vrai aussi dans les dents longues dans
les cosmétiques on découvre finalement
il ya des choses des produits non nocifs
mais qui coûte peut-être un peu plus
cher à fabriquer mais qui ne porte pas
atteinte à la santé et donc c'est comme
c'est ça je pense qu'il faut trouver en
revanche si je puis schiste pu me
permettre justement une des propositions
du de la convention avec laquelle je ne
suis pas d'accord c'est quand on a dit
il faut manger moins de viande et -
produits laitiers mais extravagant
d'entendre ça pourquoi d'abord parce
qu'il ya plein de familles qui peuvent
pas se payer de la viande donc déjà
entendre ça ou des bons produits
laitiers le gorupe est d'accord avec moi
et ça c'est dramatique pour les
agriculteurs et pour la filière vous
chers et leurs épices et le système
américain
il mange quoi maintenant les enfants qui
entendent qu'ils voient un téléphone
manger moins de viande il mange quoi des
pizzas grâce des céréales importées ou
bourrés de pesticides alors que ce qu'il
faut c'est la qualité c'est la bonne
viande à leurs produits laitiers est là
la france est au premier rang tout temps
que ça c'est triste
il faut faire très attention à cette
idéologie
alimenter encore sur le juge oriente
vers le système américain est donc vers
le dd des troubles de santé des
problèmes de santé d'obésité à propos de
pollution jean-charles cola roi vous
voulez revenir sur l'idée de la taxe
carbone alors quand on parle de ça c'est
un peu explosif mais vous je vous laisse
faire
oui bien sûr je voulais vous interroger
sur ce sujet parce que c'est vrai que
donner une valeur au carbone un prix au
carbone cette importance en particulier
pour le sujet des gaz à effet de serre
les émissions de co2 vous même vous
apportez à de nombreuses résistances
puisque vous avez voulu mettre en place
une fiscalité sur le gazole des poids
lourds la fameuse écotaxe avait été
votée avant mais avec les manifestations
et autres iront très violente des
bonnets rouges vous avez connu ça bien
sûr oui vous avez arrêté ça et
effectivement aujourd'hui comment
remettre en place une fiscalité du
carbone en particulier à l'échelle
européenne
voilà moi je suis intéressé pour avoir
votre avis là-dessus comment créer du
consensus avec des pays part en
particulier des pays de l'est où il y a
une forte dépendance au charbon
et puis est-ce que vous êtes favorable
au maintien des exonérations pour
certains facteurs je pense par exemple
aux pêcheurs ou aux routiers qui
aujourd'hui payent moins cher leur
gazole leur carburant et bien comment
faire cette convergence sans forcément
que cela crée des manifestations trop
violentes comme la crise des bonnets
rouges
je pense qu'il faut pour adapter le même
principe c'est à dire la transition
énergétique pour les pêcheurs et les
routiers c'est quoi la transition
énergétique c'est les biocarburants et
ceux qui mettent en place des
biocarburants et donc ça fait aussi un
débouché pour l'agriculture
donc ça il faut accélérer les
biocarburants le biogaz ou diderot jeu
le gazole et au rejet de fer accélérant
cela et ça donne des débouchés locaux
non délocalisables sur la taxe carbone
sur le prix du carbone ça vous fait ça
fait monter les prix le prix du carbone
donc quand vous mettez une taxe carbone
pourquoi la taxe carbone a suscité gilet
jaune et les révoltes
c'est parce que les gens qui habitent
dans les périphéries donc ils ont moins
d'argent
finalement se sont sentis racketter
parce que tout d'un coup ils sont ils
obligés ils sont obligés de prendre leur
voiture
elles se sont senties racketter milieu
rural 1 en milieu rural en milieu rural
et dans les périphéries des villes et un
au départ un gilet jaune sur deux est
une femme une femme petit avec des
petites
traître qui a besoin de sa voiture des
tilleuls à ses petits enfants etc ou des
petits salem donc donc il faut faire
très attention à ça et l'éco taxe c'est
pas moi qui les fait j'en ai chanté
irrité et j'ai vu la bestialité
l'écotaxe pardon mais quand les
producteurs de chou fleur de bretagne
payer l'écotaxe comme les grands de
transporteurs internationaux qui
prenaient leur essence dans belgique et
traversé toute la france et c'était la
même écotaxe que nos transporteuses
justement pourquoi ne pas l'avoir adapté
à propos de principe est plutôt assez
bon assez favorable de taxer les
routiers qui traversent nos territoires
et donc c'est jean-pierre de justement à
la réponse à votre deuxième caisse
pourquoi pas eu d'écho taxeront point là
j'ai dit mettons l'éco taxe aux
frontières mais paie rien ne s'est passé
mais rien ne s'est passé alors comment
faire eh bien vous mettre l'éco taxe aux
frontières fokine des commandes
européennes comment créer du consensus
il faut remettre remettre le moulant ça
en mouvement et faire en sorte d'obtenir
une décision européenne sur lui mais
vous n'avez pas réussi finalement
pendant cinq ans non parce que moi ce
qu'on m'a dit c'est accepter pas
possible dans le cas des normes
européennes ce que je crois pas je pense
que c'était parfaitement possible mais
ya pas eu de consensus au niveau
européen nous envoie j'ai freiné des
crotales était une absurdité
je voulais abandonner la taxe carbone on
aurait dû en 48 heures on l'aurait
enlevée on n'aurait pas eu les gilet
jaune à sur ce sujet le problème de la
france c'est qu'elle a inventé lé té i
pp en fin de sa peine plus comme ça
maintenant une taxe lourde sur les
carburants et est donc on arrive à un
prix maximum du carburant alors même que
la suède par exemple a pu faire une taxe
carbone un éco taxe sur le carburant
parce qu'il n'avait pas cette équipe et
donc notre pays pp c'est une taxe c'est
une équipe taxe carbone oui c'est une
écotaxe déjà faut le dire aux lilas oui
alors du coup du coup du coup je
recherche que l'ars oi est ce que le
gouvernement actuel il y arrivera à
cette écotaxe européenne d'après vous
est ce que vous êtes en train de dire à
ségolène royal que vous allez réussir ce
qu'elle n'a pas réussi pu faire non je
je je la mets aussi devant ses
responsabilités et nos responsabilités
collectives c'est que effectivement il
ya un consensus à trouver à l'échelle
européenne
effectivement en france si nous
remettons une fiscalité sur le carbone
il faut de la justice sociale et je
crois que ça c'est ainsi qu'on peut
tirer des enseignements de la crise des
gilet jaune
mais avancées au plan européen ce n'est
pas simple et ça prend du temps donc il
faut aussi ne pas mentir aux français et
ne pas leur faire croire que ça serait
simple de mettre une taxe carbone à
l'échelle de l'europe d'aujourd'hui
viennent nous voulons des pense qu'on
fera avec avec cette taxe à ya d'autres
urgences que de mettre des mois je veux
bien qu'on avance sur la taxe aux
frontières si on l'a fait tant mieux
et pour faire quoi pour financer quoi
payer ce qu'il faut c'est financé du
fret ferroviaire
or le paradoxe est que le fret
ferroviaire diminue donc il faut
relancer le fret ferroviaire c'est à
dire le transport de marchandises par le
train parce que ça c'est complètement
écologique d'une part et d'autre part il
faut favoriser les circuits courts qui
est moins de transport est d'ailleurs un
des 1 est une des conséquences du
confinement
ça a été aussi un problème écologique
puisque du coup tu les gens lieu d'aller
chez les commerçants de brut de
proximité ont commandé par internet et
donc ça a fait beaucoup de transport et
le problème c'est qu amazon par exemple
pour ne plus en faire sans leur faire de
publicité
il n'intègre pas le coût de leur
pollution
c'est à dire le transport par camion des
paquets vous achetez un livre ça coûte
très très cher en terme de pollution le
transport alors que le livre peut coûter
1 euros alors que coûte un euro sauf que
la pollution et les ailes carbone
produit par amazon il n'est pas taxée
j'espère que vous ne vendez pas votre
livre sur amazon abbas il est vendu ça
existe critiqué pendant le confinement
les librairies ne restent pas ouverte
bon et les voyez par exemple alors ça
paraît anecdotique baisser le fait
d'encourager les circuits courts
mais comme héros non on va s'inviter sur
le circuit court vous avez noté ces
derniers vous oui que dès que le ddd
confinement eu lieu les circuits courts
sont en train de disparaître ça il est
terrible et donc cela il faudra prendre
une prise de conscience
merci bruno sido merci jean charles cola
roi d'être venu sur le plateau
d'auditions publiques et d'avoir des
battues avec ségolène royal on va faire
un détour par le figaro live où nous
attend vincent roux blanc soit 20 cents
parce que nos téléspectateurs release
l'actualité notamment sur le figaro ils
suivent les débats sur les filles en
live et auditions publiques
et qu'est ce qui ressort de tout ça
bien entendu les articles les plus lus
sur les articles qui concernent le
remaniement aujourd'hui et parmi les
articles les plus lus notamment sur le
site du figaro celui intitulé quand
macro contredit déjà castex notamment
sur la date du discours de politique
générale les tweets présidentielle sur
l'objectif assigné au nouveau
gouvernement
hees a inspiré ce commentaire à cet
internaute qui se fait appeler rebelles
castex sert de vitrine à jupiter qui
continuera à tenir les ficelles
changement de casting n'est pas un
changement de politique
et vous qu'en pensez-vous ségolène royal
alors déjà sur sa première partie de la
question qui est que le président de la
république va intervenir avant le
discours de politique générale du
premier ministre
cette méthode ça vous choque ça choque
apparemment les téléspectateurs non ça
me choque pas il va intervenir le 14
juillet oui oui c'est pas la fête
nationale non mais le pro ministre va
faire son discours de politique générale
après mais oui ça me choque pas non
c'est normal elle lancé le président de
la république nomme son premier ministre
donne les grandes orientations il se
trouve que le 14 juillet est là
donc le problème présent la république
va s'exprimer et sur le côté genc pa et
pire on sait tout le monde sait tout le
monde a bien compris qu'il voulait
reprend la main sur la politique sur les
grandes orientations sur les décisions
donc voilà jean castex comme disent je
reprends les questions que vincent
évoqué des questions de téléspectateurs
vont tous vous dit à vincent si je me
trompe mais jean castex
il est là pour redonner du lustre à
emmanuel macron je pense qu'en début de
composition d'un gouvernement c'est trop
tôt pour pour critiquer ou pour deux
pour donner des impressions comme ça la
vie tu comprends que les internautes
lefa s'invitent en politique je dis
attendant de voir ce qui se passe mais
pas le juger comme ça alors que
commencer le gouvernement n'a même pas
une heure d'existence
on va on va voir merci 20 jours il ya
une suspicion
oui les il ya une suspicion sa graine
royal c'est que le changement de casting
mais pas un changement de politique
vous votre point de vue justement sur
sur sa vue qu'on connaît le casting
alors pour être très précises là dessus
il ya eu il ya une contre il ya un peu
une contradiction entre effectivement
les déclarations d' emmanuel macron qui
dit qu'il va se réinventer qui va tenir
compte de ce qui a été dit dans les
scrutins avant le scrutin des élections
municipales et le casting qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas profondément à un grand
changement par rapport au gouvernement
précédent
c'est le même profil c'est le même type
de voyage un petit pot logis de deux
ministres dont beaucoup qui reste il n'y
a pas de need élargissement massif vers
l'écologie ni d'élargissement vers la
gauche il a pris aussi merci vincent
mignot c'est pas un gouvernement d'union
nationale car nous a rejoint françois
reeves
on va sentir son gouvernement pour
commencer on continue sur le
gouvernement avec vous oui alors il ya
du figure vous dit il n'y a pas grand
changement s'il ya une figure qui se
dégage c'est eric dupond moretti qui
devient garde des sceaux de la fidh
chroniqueur sur europe 1 dans son show
et grande figure du barreau est
considéré comme tel et avec une
personnalité très forte dose très
indépendante
c'est une bonne idée de le nommer garde
des sceaux là aussi on va juger sur le
résultat et sur les actes mais c'est
vrai que cet étonnant dans la mesure où
encore très récemment eric dupond
moretti et je crois avait déposé plainte
à déposer plainte sur contre le peu le
parquet avec le parquet général
pour les magistrats c'est bizarre ça m'a
fait assez étrange c'est pour flatter
les avocats qui sont quand même très en
colère sur la réforme des retraites
notamment
je ne crois pas je pense que
je ne sais pas quelle est la raison de
cette nomination maintenant eric
dupond-moretti pu très bien joué son
rôle sa mise en scène et c'est en tant
qu'avocat serait médias ça et là ça va
le bon avocat qui joue bien son rôle
d'avocat qui se scandalisent et cetera
et puis se met vraiment dans le ce que
fo ni ses habits déchirés il faut être
sur cette discipline quand on est
ministre quand même un fou de certaines
disciplines oui et vous le voyez dans
cette discipline s'est il va faire ses
preuves mais c'est très étonnant la
politique parce que vous voyez dans la
vie politique des personnalités ou que
vous ne pensez pas forcément apte à
occuper des fonctions nouvelles et en
affaires la mutation personnel pour
occuper des fonctions nouvelles et puis
d'autres c'est une révélation et donne
est parfois si le révèle as accord alors
sénatoriales mais vous avez déclaré il
ya une semaine
moi j'aimerais bien être la femme du
rassemblement qui rassemble à gauche qui
rassemble les écologistes est-ce que
depuis une semaine puisque vous avez
fait ces déclarations et une semaine est
ce que vous avez j'ai entendu tout bien
sûr dire aux différents examens voulait
jouer la modestie est ce que vous avez
contacté depuis et bien certaines
figurent justement de cette gauche
je pense à yannick jadot jadot
écologiste je pense à monsieur olivier
faur du parti socialiste et puis
peut-être à d'autres aussi ben oui j'ai
des contacts
qu'est ce qui est des contrats mais je
me suis pas mis en mouvement de contact
pour l'instant parce que vous avez aimé
les élections municipales
donc chacun étaient à la tâche quand
même sur les élections sur les élections
municipales donc là ils viennent d'avoir
lieu les maires ont été désignés et
c'est donc c'est que maintenant que les
choses le travail va commencer surtout à
la rentrée et est ce que vous comprenez
dans cet ensemble l'année cola hulot qui
a été le ministre d'ailleurs de
l'écologie de la transition écologique
et qui est aussi une figure médiatique
de l'écologie en france mais tout le
monde est bienvenu dans ce rassemblement
mais au delà des personnalités c'est
plutôt la convergence des grands
mouvements de pensée des grandes d'aidé
grande conviction d'action et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé au cours de ces
élections municipales on a vu que ça
fonctionnait que quand la gauche et les
écologistes
rassemblez ça fonctionne non c'est un
endroit particulier à marseille
partout toutes les villes gagnées par
les écologistes ont été parce qu'ils
sont ils ont été soutenus par la gauche
et inversement
il ya eu un ou deux cas seulement il
n'était pas en accord strasbourg
poitiers logis sont gagnées ailleurs la
gauche a gagné sans les écologistes mais
quand ils sont unis et quand nous sommes
unis nous sommes très forts parce que si
vous prenez le cas de marseille par
exemple un amaury bironneau qui vient
d'ailleurs de du mouvement écologiste
non elle avait une liste écologiste
contre un email personnellement oui je l
avais ni c'est que la vie elle est
associée dans cette majorité avec des
socialistes avec des communismes
monsieur coppola qui est une figurine de
du midi et les communistes ont
productiviste ils sont pas du tout dans
une écologie comparable si vous voulez
et tout ça ça peut marcher ensemble
oui parce qu'ils peuvent évoluer aussi
oui c'était eux d'évoluer
c'est au communisme ya des mairies
communistes qui font qu'il s'engage
aussi dans l'écologie 'ça y ait des
milliers des maires socialistes qui
étaient très éloignées l'écologie sont
tous une petite y sont me progressé sur
un mois j'ai vu dans ma région en dix
ans la mutation intellectuelle et
psychologique des gens qui découvrent l
écologie qui disait ben oui il faut il
faut avancer son silence de verre je
dirais tous ces gens là sont ils
partagent tous la même écologie d'après
vous pas tous non non non ça va
difficilement alors mais ça peut être
une richesse et sa diversité
c'est plus dur à ne faire qu elle nuance
de faire l'union avec des jambes avec
une diversité une subtilité de qui est
pas qu est pas uniforme qui pas aux mots
à l'université c'est dans la rapidité
d'exécution dans la transition plus ou
moins
à long terme c'est oui c'est ça c'est un
l'arabe où vous seriez en action pour
l'écologie punitive dos d'autres crient
alors bosser la positive
vous avez la grande rigueur et la
répression de la délinquance
environnementale avait dit ça je les dis
mais je ne suis pas dans l'écho et puis
il faut sécher jamais été pour la taxe
carbone ou j'assure nicosie l'eau était
pour la taxe carbone aux échéances c'est
quoi vos échéances ça serait quoi par
exemple il faut faire ça quoi d'ici à
2050 d'ici à 2040
de quoi la transition il faut se fixer
2025 2025 2025 2030 c'est l'accord de
paris si vous êtes président de la
république c'est la corde de paris sur
le client bien si vous ne fixez pas je
vais vous dire une chose exorcisant qui
était mille fois que j'aime il faut
observer c'est que si la transition
départ rapide elle ne se fait pas donc
il faut fixer toujours des objectifs
annuels horizon exigeant car vous pouvez
toujours reculer ci s'est pas fait mais
si vous dites non c'est trop long et là
toute la logique de la bureaucratie
c'est dire c'est toujours trop long
quand j'ai internet les sacs plastiques
on m'a dit ah bah non
on va mettre six mois de plus résultat
les entreprises qui avaient commencé à
fabriquer du plastique biodégradable ont
été gravement en difficulté économie
alors avec ségolène royal à l'elysée ça
veut dire que la transition
par exemple la réduction de 75 à 50%
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire
elle se fait pendant son mandat 2025
matin elle admis depuis trois ans
maintenant donc avec d'autres à 2035
ça oui ça va plus vite et ça a vu ici
possible nous voudrions un sacré coup
d'accélérateur
écoutez si déjà si vous faites
l'isolation thermique des bâtiments vous
économiser 50 % de la consommation
énergétique du pays
donc la première énergie la moins chère
c'est celle qu'on ne consomme pas donc
si vous déployez des chantiers massif
sur l'isolation
si tous les immeubles sont couverts de
panneaux photovoltaïques
si toutes les zones commerciales ont les
bâtiments couverts de panneaux
photovoltaïques en autoconsommation vous
pouvez y arriver
ségolène royal doit être très clair et
dit vous pourriez rassemblés sous les
yeux dans les yeux
est ce que vous pourriez être candidate
c'est une probabilité c'est une
probabilité c'est une probabilité forte
probabilité forte probabilité et on
parle de faire en sorte que ça soit une
forte probabilité et on ne passe pas
mais j'ai toujours dit si quelqu'un
d'autre est mieux à même que moi de
rassembler de gagner je me mettrais
derrière mais alors tu sais pas si
c'était une forte probabilité et c'est
possible aujourd'hui emmanuel macron la
montre et d'une certaine façon vous
n'êtes plus au parti socialiste parce
que justement je supporte les candidats
et sans avoir un groupe la partie
derrière soi personne ne doute que je
suis socialiste
non non bien sûr que non mais dans mais
si c'est le cas si je suis candidate ça
sera une décision collective puisqu'il
faut rassembler ouais enfin le parti
socialiste les verts peut-être d'autres
jusqu'à la france a sonné mais bien sûr
je pense qu'il faut essayer d'avoir tout
le monde à vous une partie des
centristes vous arrivez à vous entendre
avec jean luc mélenchon en tout cas il
faut il faut essayer vous parlez
beaucoup et on ne peut je lui parle on
ne peut ré depuis longtemps puisqu'on
était dans le même goût version jeu on
ne peut réussir que si nous sommes unis
s'est aimés par réussir pour nous pour
que les français est un choix alternatif
à l'élection le mot de la fin
présidentielle le modem personne ne peut
me reprocher ne pas être écologiste
c'est bon la question sera la suivante
est-ce que ça vous paraît imaginables
envisageable que au deuxième tour en
2022 donc ça ne soit pas le match retour
de ce qui s'est passé en 2010 est
c'est-à-dire emmanuel macron et marine
le pen
mais si bien pour empêcher ça qu'il faut
où il faut et qu'il faut proposer une
alternance de me dire à moi je suis
ancien monde etc
mais je pense que l'arrivée d'une femme
à la présidence de la république
française c'est un plafond c'est à peine
justement c'est pour justement vous vous
aimez est-ce qu'on aimerait que ce soit
marine le pen la première femme
président aurait pu les noms et le fait
c'est tellement révolutionnaire surtout
dans un pays comme la france de faire
accéder une femme aux responsabilités
présidentielles je pense que le moment
est venu bien plus de chances de tours
2e tour d'après vous annuel maquereau ou
marine le pen c'est impossible à dire
pour l'instant
merci ses olives forte probabilité
d'être candidat présidentiel vous le
saurez quand
construit ça vous de ces territoires ont
besoin d'accords le déciderai quand
c'est quoi la dette la fsu ce c'est un
procès c'est un moment c'est la
politique c'est un processus on n'y a
pas de date king et yaya payet non il
n'y a pas de date en politique si susi
corps si ségolène royal l'intelligence
collective merci ségolène royal en tout
cas d'avoir participé à l'audition
publique d'abord que c'était débattre
répondre à toutes nos questions pendant
une heure c'est avec vous qu'on termine
cette saison
merci aussi à germer andrieu rédacteur
en chef fidel deux auditions publiques
delphine gouédard albert ripamonti
toutes les équipes de lcp public sénat
et le figaro qui me permettent de vous
présenter cette émission tous les lundis
en direct à 19h et on revient maintenant
en septembre dès l'été à vous à bientôt
[Musique]